The process of the browser creating and
building the document object model can be fairly complicated.
But if we're going to be precise about things,
it happens during the page load as it receives HTML source.
So, even before the page is fully loaded, the browser begins to
start constructing the document object model one piece at a time.
Other answers I would consider correct, are simply after HTML's been received,
or after the page has been loaded.
For part b, while the DOM can be accessed through a variety of different means,
the main answer I was looking for
is through its JavaScript application programming interface since we're
going to be working in the browser and with JavaScript in this course.
And in the third part, while you can access the DOM through JavaScript,
as I just mentioned, the DOM itself isn't a programming language,
or JavaScript, but is merely a specification of an interface.
The DOM is also a hierarchical object, and what I mean by this is that it has
a tree structure and this is due to the nested nature of HTML itself.